some doctors are concerned about the
potential health risks of a new drinking
water trend a growing number of people
are dropping bottled water for natural
untreated spring water or what they call
raw water one study says the average
American drank nearly 40 gallons of
bottled water in 2016 that's more than
every other drink including soda tonita
copal is in Harrison Maine at the source
for one brand of raw water called
tourmaline spring Tony good morning good
morning from where I'm standing I'm not
far from the original source of Poland
Spring which of course has become one of
the largest bottled water brands in
America and while the number of bottles
coming out of that spring house is tiny
by comparison
tourmaline spring is hoping that raw
unfiltered untreated water is both safe
and the next big thing in a bottle in
this marketing campaign the quest for
raw water is cast in a secret light a
surge of energy and peacefulness entered
my being and as we saw in this San
Francisco co-op the pitch is working
empty shells are common here with a
brand live water sells for more than 16
dollars a bottle ordering are filled or
the company says their spring water is
free of industrial toxins and rich in
healthy microbes because it is not
processed
despite the exotic footage live water
sources from the same monitored spring
that feeds a municipal tap in Madras
organ officials at the Centers for
Disease Control say water is filtered
for a reason and worn untreated water
may contain bacteria viruses and
parasites no matter how clean it looks
if you're not filtering it if you're not
disinfecting it then you are you know
creating a risk for yourself or anybody
you give the water to of diseases and
other illnesses that can come from the
water so are you taking me around 2,500
miles east in Harrison Maine tourmaline
has become another source of so-called
raw water so we're looking at a what
here bedrock high altitude high
elevation
natural spring Brian Pollan and his
partner Seth Cruzan ski say their water
is the purest you'll ever taste in part
because of its age so how old do you
think the water is they were looking at
the hydrogeologist that we had come up
your said it's at least ten thousand
years old at least
he's older water better water yes Vera
pop sure was the earth ten thousand
years ago man has contributed all these
contaminants look at the old days you
could drink out of every Lake River and
stream on the planet you can't do that
anymore what do you say to somebody
who's watching this or thinking about
this and they laughing because water is
water you drink it when you're thirsty
it goes in your body we are finding this
out
tourmaline spring is tested regularly
for contaminants to ensure it meets the
same standards as the community water
system this water is really really
important because of what's not not
because of what's in it it's so
incredibly naturally pure it has to be a
healing tonic it has to be because we're
water creatures I have customers that
swear by it but they haven't attracted
enough believers to turn a profit the
source provides thirty five million
gallons of water per year but only
one-half of one percent actually ends up
in these bottles the rest flows right
down the drain at a cost in lost revenue
of $4 per second we decided to see if it
was worth the cost any medical
interactions we should be aware of I
know CPR in case you drop it is tasty
it's very good the best mother nature
doesn't lie how I'm still standing I
should point out experts say that raw
water may contain some beneficial
minerals but a healthy diet will get you
the very same minerals without the added
risk now the water from this spring has
actually been used since the 1800s
including as a health tonic down in New
York where you are when it was selling
for about 40 cents a gallon Jeff that is
the same as $100 a gallon today Tony
thank you very much
it's a
interesting subject I think so too I
think he's right too when he says we're
water creatures and people have very
specific ideas about what they wanted
what they want their water to taste like
there's a difference did you try I was
right I looked at Tony I would try I
think there's a reason we filter our
water yeah because you don't want an
illness if you've ever gotten sick from
dirty water it's a very good one again
filled with water